reject nation can you hear us it says
our mics are working with but can you
always need confirmation
we always need confirmation jumanji two
stars in five minutes is this another
like live watch along on the tweets I
think he's just watching it oh man he's
hanging out with his family there you go
you can't stop that now can't stop Gog
confirmation first before we proceed
that we are heard hey Gabriel max gay
Aven no Tarkus detective cookie young
Sally TV Nathan do you hear us heme pena
good morning is that for us Michael
piñas friends alright guys how's
everyone doing house tellus we just want
to we're just like you know what a lot
of people are social distancing right
now a lot of people are forced to stay
at home some of you guys I hope or just
with your family having a good time yeah
for us or just like let's just hang yeah
with you God what happens so I don't
have any specific topics in mind we just
thought it would be fun and just take
whatever is going on in this chat since
I a lot of our friends are hanging out
via Skype or FaceTime like why don't we
do that with our subscribers whoever is
bored on a Saturday night or having a
Saturday morning depending on what
country you're in at the time I all
right well hello everyone so many people
Gabriel o board you see Tara Eriksson at
Tara like out in the world Isaac I would
let you kiss us on the mouth but we
can't be touching anyone's faces and you
can't be kissing yourself either elbow
bump ask us about our experiences how
are your experience how are your
experiences I'm sort of so much fun
right now how is that which shall not be
named affecting your country where are
you watching from have we binge any
movies that no no we have it honestly
things have been about the same for us
yeah because we're in here all [ __ ]
day anyway you're six days a week that's
like I just we this is my place so John
drives over here so if I think he gets
to go outside I kind of use exercise as
my chance to go outside which I still
have
to keep to a minimum cuz gyms are closed
but like they I go and I'll go running
or something like that you know but we
don't even hug now when we see each
other just like I don't know you John
we're already not obeying the social
distancing rule really so close to me
everyday I don't know about this John
yeah I don't know about this man
I'm just my goal is I'm gonna get you
sick yeah paranoia paranoia is that like
the active version of that where did you
were you at the same Sanders rally as
Jonathan pins on here I might have been
at the same Sanders rally yeah Carter's
a great leg off the livestreams
religions matched cotton Lovejoy where's
the thing where's the thing we're super
back there's where it lives is this the
beginning is this the beginning well
Carter no I think it's important to take
the situation seriously
be cautious you know every day there's a
new article coming out about how we're
blowing this out of proportion and then
there's a new article coming out about
how it's gonna be worse than we could
have ever imagined so the most important
thing we can do is be aware last thing
anyone wants is to be like those people
on spring break in Florida don't get
sick you could easily pass it along you
got to be cautious because at the end of
the day even if you're gonna be okay
at depending on your age and health you
might be able to transmit it to someone
who won't be okay people have still
passed away from from this infectious
disease so yeah I mean a more but the
zombie apocalypse no I don't think so
although I think if we do get into a
zombie apocalypse I'd be alright I feel
like I'd be pretty good in it man I feel
like if I'd be a good leader and I'd
also do some shady things behind
people's backs I'd be that kind of
leader the governor from Walking Dead
Season three you trust me but I got some
dirty secrets that's kind of leader I'd
be in a zombie apocalypse there you go
and you're probably like you know
engineering some kind of terrible oh we
got more in there they're straight guys
we gotta go back up though where's dim
sum at where's dim sum oh five at some
OH
five he says to us have you guys gone to
the drive-in theater so why are you
looking everything oh my god I got
everybody must be a hangout we're not
you were in our home everybody gotta get
the little thingy everybody gotta get
megaphone Lucas classy how you doing
buddy super chat people get the
megaphone that's how we make a special
exception to the rule here you have you
guys gone to the I've never been to a
drive-in theater you're gonna drive a
theater I hear drive-in theaters are
killing her right now I've been a staff
you I've never been to one and there are
a couple that aren't like super close
close but that are within driving
distance from here so before this is all
done if I can make it to a drive-in
theater I actually would love to do that
hey you're in your car a lot anyway I
it's my place to be a little thank you
dim sum love your profile pic by the way
it look like a good buddy of mine
actually you look beautiful let's get
another one in here all right so from
our goal yeah do you guys like birds of
prey yeah we do like birds very much
yeah I really enjoyed we were one of the
few especially as men who were one of
the few who actually really liked that
movie
quite a lot yeah I'm very surprised at
how divisive that one became I'm curious
to know what are you guys watching at
home during this time quarantine what uh
we want to see what the common Pixar cuz
Netflix is always telling me what
everyone is streaming but then I'm like
is that it or is that just my algorithm
telling me that what's up wet dreams now
keep us well we got three different
functions here what are we are you
yawning a middle my monologue here we
are we're back not even 30 yet no damn
yeah terrible hit man hustin Hudson you
be a terrible hit man but that's very
flattering maturity John read John
brought the hair down right where's all
the ladies at where my ladies with older
ladies are right this is our plan to
engage the female audience and up our
demographics to get a better YouTube
following guy here once their exact
birthdays I'm a Virgo I am a Gemini
meaning whatever those astrology signs
meaning people roll their eyes at me
when I say that yeah thanks for elbow
bother yeah we got a few elbow bumps in
the chats and elbows thank you guys so
much folks so kind of you so kind of you
well what what I've been actually doing
on my own spare time lately has been
I've been doing a lot of watching
catching up on TV shows and I actually
last night I start instead of watching
movies I Dan and Elissa moved a few
doors down from us I don't know if you
guys know them but they used to be major
regulars on the channel they'll probably
be coming back on some more they and I
started up the show Castlevania and it
was one episode we were just gonna watch
hey cuz they're like oh you gotta watch
it I was so into it we watched two more
one more episode in the first season's
done yeah that show is so good if you
haven't seen it it's great oh my god
it's incredible you guys seen
Castlevania if you're quarantine at home
start Castlevania oh and and also I'm
fully caught up now on better call Saul
and Curb Your Enthusiasm I should be
watching more movies but I've found that
I I'm also been doing on one of my
hobbies is uh cement I don't want to
talk too much about but I've been
attached to a project and been writing a
lot more in John knows how much time
consuming that's been on me and my sleep
so yeah but yeah I have you caught up on
anything I haven't caught up on a tunnel
though I did do a miniature little
back-to-back Apollo the last social
interaction I had with a friend we
watched a couple episodes of TV you know
which I've actually revisited a couple
times since then just because they're on
my mind but I've started watching like
outbreak viral episodes of stuff because
you know a lot of shows half the hose
that I thought you know especially if I
could go to a sitcom like a community
has a terrific
quarantine outbreak episode hit that guy
Rick and Morty has a great episode where
they Cronenberg the world by accident so
I've been kind of keeping myself calm
with those although yeah as things
really descend into lockdown here
because like we just just flipped the
switch my goal is to catch up yeah and a
lot more television especially because I
see so little of that yeah
official blood what are we doing oh
don't touch my hand don't touch my hat
I'm sorry witnessed it right he touched
my face day grey make this even thanks
buddy are you the bloody fury I'm David
water his water house he's back he's a
goon Waterhouse back on patreon he's
back on top he's got his own patreon
he's got funny instagrams going down
with puppets and stuff fine bloody fury
wherever books are sold
I love I love when people in the chatter
like I hope the virus goes away like
hope you guys are doing well hope the
virus goes away we're right back at you
buddy yeah yeah all we can do right now
is just try to not lose our sanity hmm
try not hoard everything and try to look
out for one another without touching
everyone you know I too can swallow I've
had to stop touching so many people
touching so many things in general yeah
I'll tell you man hey Derek Derek
Mitchell Mitch what's up guys have a
great night they're so sweet not even a
question guys if you super chat follow
it up with a question you've earned it
literally literally that's the exchange
the hair
Derek though your profile pic looks wow
you look beautiful
oh man okay so we got someone in the
chat saying if he he's in Paris Louie so
many deaths you get a ticket now if you
get on the street without special paper
from the government wow I didn't know
about that that sounds intense
is that it is intense are the brothels
so open is no risk there is the weed
still available at least for because
that sounds bad but at least you'll have
some way to pass the time you know there
you go yeah see when you're like truly
forced to stay inside like that is when
it comes like here they're still on the
wavelength of like if you have to go
somewhere you can drive there you know
disinfect yourself
don't go anywhere if you don't have to
we got someone here from Australia we
got a whole bunch of random timeslot sir
what it dude be 5 o'clock sir our to get
a bunch of random countries yeah right
yeah that's 5 o'clock somewhere here ooh
I have a feeling Thank You Aaron Jaeger
for your contribution by the way I think
he's referring to the Schmo down and I
haven't had time much to study in fact
I've had to talk with them about taking
a little bit of a step back because I've
had I've been busy with other
opportunities I wanna make sure the
channels going and I want to make sure
patreon is going well which already
takes up a lot of hours in the day and
then I also want to make sure I'm taking
care of my health my mental health and
then also pursuing my outside career
it's been a lot I was studying the lot
of the week of the last match but
honestly I don't really know how people
do it so well I don't know how people do
it man
like like how do you study and still
have a proper like social like if
there's someone who's like has a job and
then you're also trying to pursue a
different career how do you also study
for the schrodinger I don't know how to
do it and like keep up with a good
healthy lifestyle and with your proper
relationships like if you're if you just
have a job and you also just your other
passions I just really want to know
movies and comment and then also excel
in the trivia like that I can get but
for me I'm like I I don't know how to
properly balance it so I just go and
have fun now with some minimal study
yeah you know knowing that we may be
doing it more frequently now that the
factions exist and all that stuff you
know I have at least in my subconscious
said okay I'm gonna keep a better eye
out for all movie trivia the rounds my
way and then the week of is when I
to do a bit extra listening to as many
Schmo downs as I can to study up and
then case those questions come back up
that we know but to get your brain into
trivia mode you know and to kind of
awaken that side of your you know
intellect so to speak
I get that man I get that yeah yeah oh
watch movie trailers and read IMDB hey
we do love venom well I love venom I had
a great time yeah let's see here John
you're up I'm gonna switch the mode here
[Applause]
well Frankie J thank you so much it
really means a lot that you would do
shove out your hard-earned dollars what
I would say to that is no we're not
gonna get that and I feel I think I just
saw a headline recently that said that
we're it's not gonna happen
there's no and I don't think I don't
think the giant ass blockbusters like
Wonder Woman are gone they're gonna wait
though wait like two years have you seen
units don't look if they're gonna wait
and that's not even like up it's
probably a low probability will be a big
hit units but they're gonna wait but
especially with a superhero properties I
I think if Wonder Woman 1984 had come
out and then the quarantine situation
started happening then we might see the
possibility of it going like the way
we're seeing with other movies like
Invisible Man the hunt
onward going to video-on-demand but at
the moment now they have an opportunity
to put it into a different release
schedule yeah I highly done less the
situation just gets so intense that were
like we might not open theaters for two
three years they might then they might
do it not for the tentpoles yeah like
maybe you'll see it for some smaller
films or something like that you know
maybe if this experiment is especially
successful very true yet not very true
very true very cool very cool and also
really fast I do want to say to everyone
who's in this chat right now just
hanging out with us I know it's not like
the majority of the subscriber base but
hopefully this message gets out there
we're and I put a video out on patreon
yesterday talking similarly about this I
wanted to say a major thank you to all
the subscribers all you guys is everyone
here in this chap and everyone and
beyond - because I know a lot of people
right now they do have to unfortunately
some have lost their jobs some are
they're forced to not going to work now
and because of you guys were able to
still be able to keep doing what we're
doing
and no I know a lot of people aren't in
that position and so we're very
fortunate right now so it's like yeah I
wanted to come up here I didn't want to
just do a video about it but I didn't
want to take a moment how this
livestream to just quickly say that's
everybody yeah because yeah I mean this
is this is fun for us but we're also I
mean it's not like our lives are
completely unaffected by it they're
they're like we've won't go into all the
details of stuff but everything our
lives are not yeah everything outside of
what this camera's point yeah yeah
there's a there's a lot of things that
have required a lot of readjustment and
because we have family and friends and
you know I don't live alone here so yeah
there's been some serious stuff as well
that we've had to deal with but bottom
line in terms of the the work and what
we get to do we're still able to be here
in this position because of you guys so
thank you anyway
let's move on miss Marvel series don't
really know much about it but I like the
idea we did a video about we put this
video up of Captain Ammar Captain Marvel
to possibly being a cosmic horror movie
at the worst time of the day it's like
right when all the states in the world
like all these states were being told to
give an address yeah I was like oh I
didn't know that was going on and so
most people didn't watch that video but
they talked about Miss Marvel appearing
in that film and that to put a short go
watch that video but to put ashore
I will give you excited about a possible
a force team-up happening in that movie
anywho when I feel like her relationship
with Carol could be great because we
could get to know Carol in a more
maternal way through oh wow oh wait John
you gotta just no no no no no John you
gotta do your stellar impressions
stellar impression ah and do a me elf
impression without what why are you
doing the make a folk do a me elf
impression and say the message from its
meows hey Ryan
I messaged you back in 2014 from
Scotland me yeah so fact thank you meow
hey hey we we are not homosexual II
engaged but you're homosexual II married
yes that's straight damn it what's up
Placid also a Meowth yeah send to send
the message someone's asking yes it is
that double sided Punisher daredevil
sign right here signature hat Greg Alba
am i watching something that rhymes with
the corn the corn heart it's a great
film you guys should watch a real
sleeper hit but it was really exciting
stuff here Jason Bourne up yeah it's
team Pena you got do your Michael Pena
impressions a bummer we can't see a
quadrant Michael Pena from a very
specific like I don't know how to do is
actually a bummer we can't see a quiet
place or too soon though yeah it's a
real real bummer man like he's in the
rooms real bummer I did a generic white
guy making fun of Mexican accent you
know you put your own I tried I'm sorry
we try to make the super chat shout out
special for you guys it is a bummer
though it is a bummer don't worry it
will still come out one of these days
and it'll be great and you know in some
ways if it they have to put it on video
on demand might even be better you can
make sure everywhere it's quiet around
you unless your parent unless you're
young and your parents are fighting
going through one of them another
domestic violent disputes whatever then
it could be annoying yeah so maybe you
want to like put headphones on watch on
your phone but then maybe your dad steps
in snatches the phone at your hand yeah
or like go watching movies do something
with your life Pena hits you across the
face with a belt it happens anyway the
reason we're doing this live starters
want to get you your mind off of
hard times yes yes indeed not like the
post-apocalyptic world of a quiet place
domestically violent home apparently
that you marathoning peaky blinders and
just watch Emma oh yeah I heard Emma
just went through video on-demand and we
went through and like the peaky blinders
loved popping up on my radar lately is
huge I didn't know there was like such a
dedicated fan base really yeah in fact
when we were picking new patreon shows I
got way more votes than I expected at
least four for peaky blinders in huh
well John answer something else while I
pull up another question here all right
let's see will there be another baby
boom called the corona no I can see it
happening man we are we our chat thing
is a little too advanced now to show all
those oh damn okay well we're still we
can still shout you guys out probably
don't worry
nerado we're still so new to the system
here where's the microphone you've got
it you've got the mic all right John
shout Niraj out his question Thank You
Niraj to the super chat buddy and your
Christopher Walken impression become the
walking dead hypothetically what's the
plan who will be in your group
oh for sure for sure Dwayne and Jaz
those reactors never met them I don't
even know if they know who I am but for
sure okay I feel like there are back and
forth we keeping you wildly under
tanki's you got it you gotta keep in
mind guys it's probably for most of the
time pretty [ __ ] boring you know it's
probably a really dull experience it's
like I think a part of you in an
apocalypse it's kind of craving a zombie
horde just to spice up the day and so
what you want her is a couple who has
the potentiality to probably get in a
fight and I just kind of see that in
twinning Jess I'm hoping this mention
gets them to notice me that's what I'm
trying to do then so then okay but um
yeah those are my picks
fix okay Cory and Martin from double
toasted cuz they'll keep me you know
enthused throughout maybe the flick pic
because he can you know he's big and
buff and you need at least one but I
don't want you don't want flick pic on
your team because he's gonna constantly
leave the groups go work out alright I
know about Tyrone Tyrone would do the
same they are they would just be like
but we need your strength to help
protect us and they would go I can't get
strong unless I take my creatine and go
die in like a drugstore on I know his
team run getting a but jug of Soylent or
something ok fine then then I'll take
Evan Dollard and that's final and he's
got a sense of humor about working out
yes I feel like he'd be fine oh okay we
got Elm Street up in here all right give
me some ladies on my apocalypse
all right I'm gonna do my Christopher
Walken impression mm-hmm all right
mine is more subtle than John's totally
a lot more like his real but a lot a lot
more accurate I got to tell you guys way
more accurate this is to Elm Street have
you plied spawn in Mortal Kombat it's
fun see it was great the key is to
embody him yeah their imagination
memories are your own thank you super
Jeff buddy have we played spa I I
haven't yet but Dan and Elissa our major
gamer she's the editor for game theory
so he's probably gonna get Mortal Kombat
yeah I think he has Mortal Kombat so one
of the games are gonna play are gonna be
me going over there wearing my gloves in
my mask and going can i play your video
games full hazmats
oh wait I can buy Mortal Kombat I could
probably download it yeah
oh come back to me in a week come back
yeah we'll just do Joker versus spawn
all night long hey hey Elm Street has it
been a nightmare for you out there
welcome to
prime time [ __ ] oh dude the knocker
first live ever watching thank you and
and watching here in Iran what what is
it like over there given the corona by
that the thing we shouldn't name it's
too late I've already said too many
swear words dude tell you I messed this
up okay so we got uh long as it wasn't
me oh yeah I was talking about earlier
our friend from Austria over here
better call Saul been killing it this
season just got to tell you guys yeah
and the actor who plays nacho I just
realized today
he played scorpion in homecoming so late
to figuring that out he's in karbala
Jeff you guys had a watch better call
Saul you got to give it a shot you
better so good huh it's all good man
hahahaha Breaking Bad okay Matthew
Holmes
okay you got to say his shout out and
you got to say his shout out oh we got
the stuff back yeah guys say it in your
best Trump impression Matthew Holmes
everyone get this is from check the
biggest checks I've talked to every bank
they said Trump I love you checks see
mine mine gets a little too up in the no
down here everyone gets a trump check
you sound like how they may put a nerds
in like I know see the problem is lately
one gets a chump check with all this
stuff going on with the pandemic and
everything I I have literally stopped
paying attention to the White House
because like nothing Trump has to say
about this is helpful so I've just not
been paying attention to him and paying
attention to everywhere human dr. Fauci
are on the same page
all the time all right I mean if I was
to combine constantly they're all they
always compliment each other very well
we'll keep we'll keep it at that thank
you so much Matthew Holmes by the way I
really do appreciate that buddy I'll see
for LT you we did answer your question
already buddy dude oh hey whoa whoa wait
a minute wait a minute there's case in
Corpus Christi's Cameron believe you
thank you buddy
Dylan you here's what I'll do right now
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna pull
up I'm gonna pull up tie Ronan's mess on
message on my phone oh my god there's an
audio message from him I did not respond
you know dude
okay well here let me just um you should
FaceTime him how do I do the voice thing
on on on this okay so um hmm oh my god I
never do this
oh he always there's okay all right I'm
gonna send him a message for yes here we
go here we go
hey Tyrone Greg here no John you don't
listen I'm so sorry
hold on it doesn't matter I'm gonna send
a message for you I'm just gonna text
him maybe put it to your ear while you
have the text oh it doesn't matter John
it's too late it's too late we've lost
45 people on this livestream I four
little bad all right I'm gonna do a
video videoing the chat here oh I don't
hey Tyrone doing a livestream right now
and someone just asked a camera in view
he call Tyrone max said hi I didn't want
to risk you not answering your phone so
I'm here today sending you this video
message you don't need a reply now you
have to send it right this minute though
I'm sending I'm sending right to him BAM
this will be this is not this will be
the new forms of the super chats is what
message do you want me to send Tyrone
there we go that's that's what we'll do
we can't cut him in on this that's what
we'll do yeah I know wait he'll and I
know him he's a greedy son of a [ __ ]
he'll he'll ask it'd be like where's the
money where's the moolah it's 1:30 p.m.
in Austria I'm sorry different timezones
yeah where can we find a microphone like
that Amazon amazon.com this video today
is sponsored by amazon.com yes they're
hiring more workers hopefully to treat
better yeah let's go where's the thing
whoa John know where people are over the
megaphone all right do your Arnold
Schwarzenegger impression
thank you MiG's Excel thank you so much
I shout him out how are you doing is
because Arnold now I feel like there's
so many bad arlen compressions that
they've surpassed walkin and now you
better try
so here is X I just wanted to say thank
you for the years of great content you
guys have a fantastic roll of toilet
paper I can have every roll of toilet
paper will cost you $10 exact so you
know mom where do you live
I bought 240 toilet paper rolls I am the
problem I am part of the problem that I
have criticized because I wasn't part of
the problem then people created the prom
so then I went out there and was like
well I better hoard a bunch because
other people are hoarding it and now I
just fed into the vicious cycle so if
you want to roll a toilet paper it's
gonna be $10 mm-hmm already contributed
so congratulations
you are getting a roll a toilet paper
well done
that should be our giveaway people have
always said do giveaways I'm like I
don't know how to do giveaways oh my god
people might hear the real rejects every
every Saturday the giveaway people
should you like a sheet of toilet paper
yeah we'll give you five squares that
should be enough a smidge that makes
Excel really appreciate it but we're the
only reaction videos you just lost your
comment but someone here said we're the
only reaction videos you care about
thank you so much you don't know what it
is you know but I've always like it's
the waning jazz though they're the ones
yeah all chants blasphemous HD they're
the ones
Steve's here what's up Scoob hey guys
hey guys up a meowth is back Oh answers
questioning your mouth impression that
was your best one you've done so far
yeah I asked you to react TAS so
trailers me yep that's right and that's
the only reason I did it I was like I
don't care about the amazing spider-man
no one's gonna watch his reactions only
did it for you meow thank you
such a gentleman such a kind gentleman
oh oh scuba Steve send a sticker if you
were in New York right now or no he's
not from there that's right I always get
wrong excuse what is the super stickers
do what we got a super sticker right
here we just can't show it Oz for you
thank you so much for the super sticker
thank you buddy
Steve where are you from damn it Rhode
Island New Jersey
no it's Rhode Islanders
Maryland now Rhode Island guy Rhode
Island talked to him I talked to him and
I just can't remember who's from so uh
yeah
stop tagging right now stop graffitiing
okay yeah you're gonna get arrested
you're not old ID not a lot to be
outside graffiti online do you guys
really think venom 2 is gonna be better
I've seen a lot of people going back and
forth in this chat about venom to I mean
the first venom could have been better
watch a little though you know level 2
training watching the haunting of Hill
House great thing to watch right now
watch spooky stuff it's out I hope it is
that way your last nail Charlie I'll
bark constantly oh my god we know what
the B stands for go dude first Michael B
now this well we know certain Randall's
are doing movie reactions on YouTube and
we were that we have a friend Jason
Dolan now who is constantly hitting me
up every day about doing movie reactions
on here I don't know do you guys think
we should do it do you think people
would really care I think it would be
fun but yeah it's got to be the tech cut
so the great convergence between
Pleasants of viewing and also people's
where's what I mean I don't know about
watching a new movie but yeah maybe like
something so bad it's good or something
that's like classic or something that
would be fun to do it yeah because so
I'm watching a new movie right so I'm
watching Emma on here I'm gonna want to
watch Emma yeah but that means like
people are people are talking about
animal reactions are burning up yeah
they are it's true they are it's crazy
you know the new BTS just jane austen
all day long man hey hey be safe the
people here in the chat talking about
that if they caught Corona they might
actually they could be fatal for them so
be as cautious as possible look out for
your neighbors do we think Falcon and
Winter Soldier will walk and still come
on in August up at reproduction hell no
probably not done with course yes no
definitely not the only way I think any
shows are gonna continue is if the
series are done
love you too placid oh oh my god we got
I and the Cobra the Chi oh do do your
best Ralph Macchio or if you can't
somebody reflects you guys are the best
apocalypse really had me dying which you
guys recommend a movie for everybody's
to watch anime etc why that's why Ralph
Macchio it's okay it's okay you did your
pal zero my Johnny Lawrence then the
real rejects you guys are the best
apocalypse really had me dying which you
guys recommending movie for everybody's
to watch anime etc I don't read this
question twice and I don't get it
I think we're looking for um you know
anime movie recommendations
okay yeah movies for people who watch
anime I mean it's not anime specifically
but if you haven't seen Alita it's it's
could be better but it's also a pretty
great step in the right direction
towards live-action anime adaptation IMO
when I was younger the only anime I
watched was Pokemon right and then one
day my friend named Yong Chun that's his
real name of Yong Yong gave me a VHS
copy of an anime called Ninja Scroll not
even a teenager yet and my impression of
anime is that it was for children I was
a kid I put this on and there are just
disturbing scenes in that movie I want
to see this so disturbing and that's
what I recommend your way during this
time it's the first anime movie that
turned me off of anime for a few years
because I thought all them were this so
go watch Ninja Scroll that's my
recommendation to the Kai okay yeah I
see I feel like all my recs would be
basically goes to the shell or like you
know Princess Mononoke bin Rises I'm
Batman and Iron Man I appreciate that
Gabriel Lopez such a nerd chronic Eric
but Eric everybody say thank you to Eric
Eric just so you know this $5 is going
right back into your bank account the
next time we hire you to edit one of our
TV show yes all right
we're gonna make a little we're gonna
take your fight put it in
pile right there so just keep super
chatting until it equates to what it
costs to hire you to edit a video yeah
he's also the editor for the movie
trivia Schmo down now yeah gratulations
such a great gig movin on up and
seriously he's cut our game of Thrones
and stranger things and man don't watch
along so if you saw those on YouTube
Eric was instrumental in getting those
up oh I was worried this would happen
the Crick and nerds said that I thought
we were having an SNL stream here well
if we did that it would get blocked yes
secondly I thought it was like a fun
play Saturday Night Live Stream but I
was also worried of what you were
talking about that some people think we
are talking about Saturday Night Live
stuff but they're also not happening
right now because of the Thule ahead uh
huh Trump's anchor Chinese virus oh man
I like this is here to remind us that
that like that stuff like the borders
and everything don't matter like if this
affects all of us so I think it's really
dumb all right all right okay now I'm
gonna do my Arnold impression like
John's - so much better okay oh the way
how John failed I step aside at the
Walken impression I'm gonna excel here
and show you what a real Arnold
impression sounds like thank you right
Angie Sanderson for your super chef
eyewear and these are the quarantine
related Chapter blinds a good peek of
all I've got is one the former Kate
while we isolate I love from the Costco
oh let's see hmm
whoa this is where you're supposed to be
like I mean oh what was that oh my god
answer him Josh well let's see let's see
let's get steamy in here let's see do
you want a quarantine net net Corp
Netflix and corrent quarantine and chill
um
did it hurt what when you got inoculated
for coming ha see I'm not good at pickup
lines let's do this I know I'll get
better this moment fornicate while we
isolate see the Ryan
is what makes that work so well and I'm
trying to think like hey hey girl you
wanna flip my lid while we hide out from
Co vid are you Kovac because you look 19
uh do you have Corona if not I wanna
bogna hey there you go talking about the
drink not the virus don't be a perfect
job yes yes yes put a lion I wanna bone
alcoholics in a minute put lime Oh Jose
Velazquez happy birthday to you buddy
how are all these I'm so sorry birthdays
happen during this time happy
non-copyright birthday - boo but you
know what you know what though it's it's
better that you're being smart and
staying at home social distancing I'm
like that [ __ ] idiot I saw on the
news I was like I'm 21 I want a party a
string bag on the base my friend let the
virus hold me back young people have
died too young no Corinne I will not
show you out okay Corinne I never shout
out Corinne happen not a story night
Corinne
okay yeah hey Elm Street the nightmare
is back and has been a blast more people
or sleep so how because I said has it
been a nightmare for yeah I get it
took me a second to remember that yoga
made riders there the three master man
doing great thanks again buddy
you're so sweet so sweet better call
Saul Rafi oh my god Thank You ghost
ghost man Saul good night on our
Depression so every time I hear Mike
Ehrmantraut calls every time I hear him
talk I'm like I can do that then I try
it and I never can do it every I've
never been able to pull it up but it
sounds like a voice I could pull off but
I can't do you got a slow down you drawl
and you got to put a little bit of an
accent as good as closer than mine
watching his Conan menstruation
interview I'll give you a super like
Stardust 30 second review of better call
Saul when the show first started
took me a little bit of time to get past
the fact that how different this was
than Breaking Bad it really is a law
procedural show and so you really get
immersed in the kit but eventually you
find that you get really immersed in the
slice-of-life deliberate pacing and by
the time you get to season 3 it starts
becoming more of a Breaking Bad prequel
now we're like in real Breaking Bad
prequel territory but in some ways the
idea of knowing there's a tragedy coming
because Breaking Bad hinged off of the
potential hope that he might go back on
this right so you're watching this nice
guy evolve into a monster whereas with
Jimmy you're watching him trying to do
the right thing but his luck just keeps
turning back on him and so you're
watching him eventually given to the the
image that people always view of him and
that tragedy element but but the other
supporting characters become so fleshed
out people like nacho Gus fring becomes
a main character in there and it never
feels like just you know fanservice
treatment it's always always just it's
some of the best writing I've ever seen
on TV it's hard it's hard it's I feel
like I would have to be in a podcast to
really deep dive into the Kim Wexler the
actions I think rias seehorn is her name
incredible Mike Ehrmantraut what's that
actor's name but he's [ __ ] awesome
like now they're all so good you got a
watch better call Saul and I feel like
it's like has a big fan base but it's
not really the most internet talked
about show you know I'm talking about
that's a crisp thirty seconds well done
yeah artists review follows on Stardust
by the way if you don't know what the
app is it's really the one percent
Barney
Alvarado hi guys I love watching your
guys's videos I'm chilling with my cat
staying safe and healthy I enjoy hearing
your movie reviews see this Bernie yes
the thing is I think your Bernie is is
like trapped I mean what are your
impressions no not at all giving you a
tip I'm saying I think your Bernie got
trapped in in the teleportation machine
with Al Pacino oh yeah I know what's
gonna happen they're both from New York
and they're old with deep
New York accidents alright it's gonna
happen thank you so much Bernie Alvarado
hey I got four cats and a squirrel now
so I know what the love of animals is
like thank you so much you're gonna be
living in a Disney movie pretty soon and
they're gonna help you like make your
bed
what is enos enos um okay I I don't know
but thanks for asking me no by the way
what Funko pops from the background too
many Funko pops not as much as other
youtubers but there's a pretty good
amount of Funko pops let's say that a
lot of them are from Rosa para by the
way I'll did a game of Thrones ones have
you guys heard the car DB Nick
coronavirus it's getting real and then
someone took her saying that and turned
it into a song wait was this Tom
McDonald it's so catchy so catchy
was it Tom McDonald was it the white guy
with the the dreads and the I don't know
who made it and all the time it's really
good it's great stuff seriously every
time some livia that my girlfriend I are
always going around
we'll just the colonel virus it's
brought up coronavirus we always do that
it's a way to make the coronavirus sound
fun yeah exactly makes it sound like a
party may be funny go lie more often we
might have found our time slot we might
have found let's see here you're part
Filipino Greg you should use tab oh oh
I'm a terrible Filipino for not knowing
what you're talking about but whenever I
see another Filipino always go put away
pride and they're like it's like when a
Marvel trailer movie is Breanna in the
chat Brianne Chandler somebody sends a
response to Miss movies hey miss movies
brand Chandler oh she is she's always
such a support of human being to us a
lover I didn't see when you came in but
I'm so happy that you're here have very
few actual friends from the Schmo damn
like there are people I see at the Schmo
down and then I have people who I
consider like no this is this is a
person I consider a real friend and
Brianne Chandler is one of them thanks
Fran for being here just wanted to
mention that really fast we're trying to
go in the order of everything yeah who's
next
I was the last one better Tulsa okay so
we got my Brittany lame up go up
Brittany then we'll find you Brittany oh
and OH
well five years oh she is good oh my god
oh my god oh my god we gotta fill up we
gotta fill the place we're getting close
live we gotta fill the play film with
that space here cut the commercial hey
guys
oh no John we gotta get you another
impression Stephen Lang do your best
even laying impression hey guys
oh yes how you guys seen any gameplay
ado material since it came out Friday I
could do you one better
Dan I mean I can't get too detailed here
but Dan has it and well Matt can get D
so when we're talking about secret yeah
I thought I got like an early copy um he
has it I'm planning on going over and
actually playing with him said I just
watching gameplay but maybe we'll do a
reaction to some gameplay already laughs
I mean doom is a super fun danza dan is
dan is one of those people who made me
really appreciate doom significantly
more because he really knows a lot about
the lore and the story and he wants to
create something special out of it so he
haven't I've seen some of it on my own
time think we yeah but I think we've
done a reaction to one of those yeah we
know the eternal like III trailers
that's such a great photo by the way
pretty you're looking great looking
awesome I didn't mean that in a
respectable way okay respect respect all
right all right miss movies is next I
think I know this is this is the mo no
Brittany Lang's back the gameplay of
doom its yeah we got it
you didn't have to super chat more I
mean thank you but yes
Hey look I know you guys some of you
guys are bored in quarantine so yes keep
talking with us recording around here
Greg where are you willing to watch us
let's see here okay
I'm great I wouldn't want people in a
watch oh that's probably my own time my
stream alone is great yeah
let's watch John stream along without
syncing up the footage to shield let's
see if I can really latch on to what's
going on with the show oh yeah what
movie are we most bummed about being
delayed I mean I guess right now I would
say feel like the right answer to say
considering the channel would be Black
Widow but I would say a quiet place
to spiral spiral as far was really so
many months so like so many months but
months away that that I was that wasn't
as much of a big deal but quiet place to
we had tickets yeah you know we don't
get screening for advanced screenings
for anything so we had tickets and well
fourteen and we were we were like I got
my perfect center seat I saw the trailer
in IMAX and I was like I gotta watch
this in IMAX and yeah I was really
excited for it and I heard amazing thing
so that's why the one that bummed me out
the most the immunes what about you guys
which is the one that's bumming you guys
out the most that's a fun question to
throw at the audience yeah what's a
bummer
what's a bummer for you yes oh okay a
Breanna Smoot Madam's cinema should I
live stream okay um I'll do my Stacie
Howard impression I have to say should I
live stream is also my voice that's not
true I just I don't know how to
distinguish the voices with my own
impressions should I show live stream i
guitar lesson
also i'm terrible.i guitar yes I think
that'd be so cool because people could
watch your progress as you go and I've
seen you play guitar on social media I
don't think you're terrible
so Brianne do it yeah do it I say do it
do the Marge Simpson stay one lesson
ahead of everybody and be I mean think
of it if you start live streaming you
could we could patch you into one of our
live streams as the musical guest yes
like a like a late-night talk show so I
say build that following play that
guitar and someday we'll cut a record
together
hey out of all the Batman's and Joker's
in the movie in the worlds which one you
want to see match up against each other
Val Kilmer's and Jared Leto's because no
one would see that coming and I'm a ryan
Johnson supporter so do that and I think
Ryan Johnson would choose those two
cesar romero versus mark hamill in the
cartoons
oh if someone asked us earlier on
patreon like
who's sexier genre Greg and I said the
woman always loved John the most and she
said John isn't Amy O'Neill said John
doesn't need lions she's just a smile
and I'm melt yeah you know it's getting
to the point where you are just
degrading John alright stop treating me
like you see me you can't just keep
treating him like that
foodie surfer 1981 oh wait no okay I
went last time John what you got a can
well Christian bio is from Leeds I'm
just going through a British accent good
I love your videos keep up the awesome
work much love from look down thank you
thank you good thank you so much mm-hmm
I always forget Christian Bale is he's
Welsh Welsh I'm not British mm-hmm
speaking of Wales the episode of Doctor
Who were gonna put up tomorrow on
patreon take split under there what
episode we put up last week took place
in Cardiff yes there you go speaking of
Wales Vanessa legend said some dumb
stuff oh yes I heard that you guys hear
the dumb stuff she's not a whale people
die in whatever pretty intelligent and
she's actually pretty fit doesn't work
the whale analogy narratives okay yeah
but no Vanessa Hudgens is comments were
pretty done a list Anissa Alissa Hey
Anissa I wrote a story recently and I
named the kid named the main female
character Anissa oh that's a fact now
she's not exactly based off you but I
took her name and you're the only
individual I've ever known to have the
name Anissa so I thought I should point
that out to you John she's in love with
you so you better shadow right here
you're a reader who better reader super
chat oh dude wait oh dude oh yeah I love
you guys live tweeting cats seriously
thank you and I'm so glad you enjoyed
that shout out because it was a blast
and a half stay strong and hey anis is
like working in hospitals and stuff so
holding it down and doing important work
so much love
hey miss movies everyone's talking to
you okay yeah I'm conflicted on
something like this um II six one five a
a one nine three nine
hey we could call you that's a phone
number you guys need to do you know
that's a phone number you guys need to
do a reaction to contagion Corona is
best for the slice of Lyme disease
thank you so much for your contribution
here see I wonder what my dark thought
was reacting to like dark movies yeah do
the crazies do what if we were to react
to movies what would it be but I
appreciate that suggestion right there
huh you got a squirrel
I got a squirrel on the other side of
this wall and he's on the light side
yeah yeah I got to keep him away from
you where is Tara Eriksen she's in
quarantine has anyone seen Tara Eriksen
call your local she okay all we still
okay now the quarantine is in effect
we'll set up that mailbox yeah yeah
that's the best time to do it right now
yeah all right so who's after
Christopher Nolan's flick getting
postponed yeah that's a bummer I do
think it is and I like Li right I liked
what he had to say about the one this is
over please still keep going to the
theaters yes yes I agree Elm Street
thank you so much for being here dude Oh
be well great nights you go to sleep
this is some dreams actually go up
there's an ER there's in the dead new
Raj what you're on his back oh okay Raj
thank you so much for the question
how many can we a person with confidence
let's see here all right oh man ah was
in the Irishman that's beautiful
that's one okay I'd even that confident
about mr. white [ __ ] I don't want to
cook today yo you do have your your meth
is good Jesse as good as mine
[Laughter]
none of these are good I used to be able
to do it Dexter's on the fourth or II
tried it in so many years that I can't
my father was a drinker and a fiend well
the drug everyone knows Joker Batman oh
my god touch my face the people always
do you right yeah all the funny voice
guy and then what else is there what
else is there
oh um Johnny Depp from about like 10
years ago well you know it's mostly
people just care to see the Terminator
oh my I'm sure I have a couple more I
just don't remember what they are best
grace impression hollyhocks has ever
heard oh that's all love okay that's all
in love we've called we've noticed each
other on the Internet
yeah my god but she sent me some weird
pics oh don't bring it up with her of
markiplier I know she's always getting
the down-low on do we like markiplier I
mean I'm a liar oh my god he's great he
I've always come people always say look
like him yeah I've actually got that in
person for the first time ever where I
walked through the door someone's home
and his roommate is like you got to look
like markiplier yeah and I always say
you know how celebrities have a twin
brother or sister and who are not as
good-looking as them that is me I am
that sibling markiplier oh my his
epitaph is Ryan
Watterson thank you so much again voice
Orson thank you dear you gamer it looked
like my friend I have a friend named
Michael you kind of look like him
look packs are movies hello Axl from I
didn't recognise the first few titles
and I was like is that a real thing
packs are movies this is good this is
like unfolding as we the meme is
unfolding as we speak I'll tell you
these are the best kind of super chats
to get yes there's no questions
it's just fun he just sounds me back
yeah thank you so much dude those are
all great film bigger tail insect cycles
great demons organized as a class these
are all good Waldo Ratatat tacular
mobiles send this send this screeners of
it and I'll send you a sheet of toilet
paper how about that Oh a sheet of news
toilet the final is ouch Cesar Luis how
you doin dude how's it going guys
Oh Bernie Alba back to the future fact
the 1% Jeff Goldblum and John Cleese
were casted to play dark brown for the
movie and the musical was in London oh
who has universal health care oh that's
a really fun fact yeah I did not I I
would there was a musical look back to
the future
oh man I but what would the would the
songs have been called there's got to be
like a theme called the 88 miles per
hour suite oh yeah oh wait now there's a
movie that they recast never catch the
movie the musicals that's a can't speak
ol black-ass for the baby Klees or
musical Back to the Future happening and
they were cast for that is every try
tell me please in the musical would be
great that'd be great yeah yeah if I
could go to London and behold it oh yeah
I thought he meant Pixar too but but I
didn't recognize any of those titles so
I'm really not sure Anna Skye as we just
put up our reaction at the season finale
season 4 of Supernatural oh my god thank
you Anissa by the way yeah incredible
mind-blowing I was really shocked yeah I
had to get off this chair that was very
wrong I didn't know about it yeah thank
you so much yeah that such a good show
took me it took us a few episodes in the
first season a real as well fan base
hype was about but yeah every time we
sit down a record I'm so looking forward
to it it's been magical yeah oh oh my
god hey your squirrel is the sweetest
thing in the world thank you so much
always keep writing love Rick Riggs he's
a survivor
Rick's mill name is Dean now because
someone's Union and a mouth for Dean's
so I was like
you know ya in Winchester alright guys
we're gonna hop off here a second got a
prep a thumbnail for tomorrow's video
but I wanted to say thank you so much to
everyone who's been here
hope you guys are finding ways to stay
entertained to be having a great time at
home what's up I'm sorry what's the
second person to be cured of HIV
oh really had no idea well that's a
great that's awesome that's one door
closes in a window and hardcore gamer I
wanted to tell you favorite DC animated
movie currently for me still holds a
title to Batman under the Red Hood love
the hell out of that one Joss Whedon's
Jost asleep my love flashpoint I love
love flashpoint that one's also really
great seen quite a bit of those but yeah
we gotta get go all right as long as you
keep paying I don't want to say that we
do going
yes but scuba sees you just did submit
this in right before we got off thank
you so much to actually oh my god got me
and I do want to someone brought up his
damn earlier brother I gotta I gotta
bring this up but scuba sees what's the
weirdest movie you guys have seen stay
safe I love everything you guys do much
love from Rhode Island all right well
they asked us to do they we got asked to
do a they were gonna pay us a thousand
dollars to review this movie yeah we
said no because ice cuz I was like if
you're gonna pay us that much money to
review this I want to watch it first and
make sure I have a positive opinion
about it and I could not find a single
positive opinion about this movie it was
so strange so weird because when someone
offers you a thousand bucks to review a
movie which has never happened before
and it does not happen again since is
the one time it's happened I remember
the title of it but it was like one of
those weird-ass like a serial killer oh
right yeah alright yes
serial killer uber driver things it was
so bizarre and so off-putting in every
way and I had to tell him like I can't
review this because I just don't I want
it I'm like if you're gonna pay us that
much money we got to make sure we like
it and we didn't it was worse
so yeah that was just something awful
that is the weirdest what I've ever seen
I thought you were gonna bring up fury
of the fists and the Golden Fleece oh no
I mean that was weird but no I could sit
through that at any day be away beyond
the other one I think the weirdest movie
I have ever seen his terror vision like
it's an 80s movie and it is lacked TF
out but um beyond the black rainbow is
pretty weird and so is the Forbidden
Zone yeah and I wanted to mention really
thank you guys to everyone who did
contribute in the super check and a
render guys names off really fast oh
good to see you again
Carter Lovejoy dim sum oh five hitmen
hast Hudson fishel bloody fury Derek
Mitchell eren yeager Frankie J it's
Meowth team Pena Niraj Krishnan Elm
Street Matthew Holmes Cameron better
than me exact so it's me y'all scuba see
films like high CEO Bartlett neurotic
Ryan Andrew Sanderson and ghost man why
see Bernie Alvarado
I think that's everyone so everyone
scoob's Eve last night at least I want
to say thank you to Dan Merle and Mara
canopic for swinging by here just the
other day to drop off some home made
pudding cupcakes to myself and Olivia
they were [ __ ] delicious thank you
guys so much
anyway much love this has been a total
blast well do try to do one at least
once a week while this whole thing is
going on because it's fun to hang out
and try to keep you guys a little bit
entertained wow you know all this from
going on sorry : King much love we'll
see you guys soon
be well